(inspiring music)
Dr. Dachs is returning
(audience applauding)
and he is going to continue
with our discussion of emergency topics,
including trauma, wound care
and the surgical abdomen.
All right, learning objectives,
here we go,
we're on injury prevention.
So, we're gonna talk about injury prevention
'cause we as primary care doctors,
we like to prevent things,
that's our role.
So, the #1 cause of injury related deaths
in the United States as of 2019
were falls, actually, falls
but right up there (chuckling)
and increasing,
and I'm sure will exceed falls,
will be firearms in the United States
and in children age zero to 18,
it is the most common cause of death
from injury in children,
MVA's are there at 36,000.
All right, speaking of MVA's and children,
you're gonna recommend car seats?
Yes.
Used to be you used to have to memorize,
you know, your zero to two,
your ages, zero to two,
two to four,
six to eight,
you know, you know,
zero to two,
you put 'em in the backseat,
face backwards from that,
it's really simple now,
just go on whatever the manufacturer recommendations
for the car seat is.
Just, that's an easy one to tell your patients,
an easy one to answer on the Boards,
just follow the manufacturer's recommendations.
When it gets to,
we're talking about children
and trauma and death,
I told you, zero to 18 is firearms,
let's go to the subgroup
of ages one to 14.
One to 14,
the most common cause
of trauma related death is drowning
and you know,
and that's why it's very important
that the recommendations
for pools in your backyard
have fencing around all four sides, okay?
You cannot use the house
as one of those sides
because the toddler
will toddle outta your house
and go right into the pool,
so you should have fencing
on all four sides of a pool
and then zero to one,
suffocation's a problem.
This is why we have the Bed to Back Program.
Get the kid's,
all the toys and blankies and binkies
out of the bassinet.
It's amazing how many infants
still sleep in the bed with the parents.
Tell them do not do that,
please do not do that.
I had one terrible SIDS death
but it wasn't SIDS death,
it was an infant,
it was a very tired father,
a good father,
a tired father had the child in his,
you know, his arms,
he was in a recliner chair
and he fell asleep,
the child's face went
into sort of his armpit area
and was suffocated.
So, be very, very wary of, yeah,
and if they're in the bed,
that's too easy for them
to roll into the parent
or some bedding.
All right, child abuse,
so they like to ask a question
occasionally on child abuse,
so let's do this.
"Child abuse should be suspected
in all the following except",
except, "7-month-old with diffuse cerebral
and retinal hemorrhages,
B, a 2-year-old with three rib fractures
after a fall,
C, a 6-month-old with multiple
lower extremity bruises from falls
or D, a 20-month-old with spiral fracture
of the distal tibia."
Which one is not child abuse?
Three of 'em are
or should be suspected.
Okay, boom, boom, yeah,
the answer there is D,
the answer there is D
and I'll go through that.
So, the other ones,
let me just go through this,
so hope, yeah,
a lot of you,
nobody picked,
or very rarely have you picked
the cerebral and retinal hemorrhages.
You see cerebral, retinal hemorrhages on an infant,
that's shaken baby syndrome
until proven otherwise,
that's an easy one.
All right, how about the bruises
on the lower extremity of a 6-month-old?
Well, 6-month-olds typically
are not toddling along, okay?
They shouldn't have bruises on their legs,
so if they don't cruise,
they don't bruise.
You don't buy the story,
"Oh, they kick the crib a lot."
Nah, nah, they're not doing it
to get multiple bruises
on their extremities.
Rib fractures in children are rare
under the age of three
because they're ribs are very hypermobile
at that time,
so the way you will often see rib fractures
in that age group
is because someone went whack, okay?
As for the spiral fracture of the distal tibia
that often is thought of as abuse,
it's not,
it's a common fracture in toddlers.
What happens in toddlers,
I'll get up here
and try to demonstrate.
For those of you
who have had children and toddlers,
you know, they just,
they go around like this
and what they do
is they will spin out one time
and they'll give themselves
a spiral fracture of the distal tibia
and so that is not abuse.
If it's a transverse fracture
of the distal tibia,
then someone went whack, okay,
so that's what,
that's the difference.
All right, that's child abuse,
let's go on to wound care
and soft tissue injuries.
"27-year-old tripped and fell in the garden,
sustaining a laceration
to the thenar eminence of the hand.
The patient noted that there
was glass silvers in the ground",
slivers, I should say,
"in the ground and is uncertain
if there's glass in the wound.
The wound is a 3 cm laceration
without active bleeding.
Despite the patient's efforts to clean the wound,
there appears to be still dirt in the wound",
'cause they didn't go at it much,
"The patient's last tetanus immunization
was seven years ago."
Got the picture?
So, "All the following
would be appropriate except",
irrigating the wound with tap water,
decontaminating the wound with Betadine,
providing a tetanus booster
or do you "obtaining an X-ray
for potentially embedded glass."
B, you don't pour Betadine into wounds.
Betadine,
full strength Betadine is cytotoxic,
don't start decontaminating wounds with Betadine,
all right?
You want the wound to heal, of course.
All right, but actually when it comes to tetanus,
we'll talk about the tetanus thing first,
is that tetanus is really, really, really rare
in the United States.
Most people who get tetanus
have never been immunized for it,
there's like 30 cases per year
in the United States.
The CDC recommendations still are the same.
In other words,
if it's a clean wound,
it's every 10 years.
I alluded this patient has a dirty wound, right?
So, then it's every five years.
If it comes in as a dirty wound
and it's been over five years,
give 'em a tetanus booster.
If they've, the booster can be a Tdap, okay,
or it can just,
you get that once,
get that once at least
and then if they come back again,
let's say 10 years later,
you can give 'em another Tdap
or you can just do a regular Td,
it doesn't matter, okay,
but one time, once,
you should at least get a Tdap.
All right, irrigating with tap water
is really good.
If you can get,
if you can numb it up,
bring 'em over to the sink,
I do that,
there's a case of ours,
just bring it over to the, you know,
to the tap water,
let it go.
Okay, numb it up,
let it go,
and here's the wound care principles
and if you think there's any glass possible,
you do an X-ray.
Glass shows up on X-ray, right,
all the way down to 2 mm.
Who goes on antibiotics?
We'll talk about this a little bit later,
but anybody who is high risk.
A high risk patient, for example,
an immunocompromised patient
or a high risk wound.
Was it a bite?
Was it a very contaminated wound?
Was it on a part of a body
that has a propensity
for getting infected
like your fingers, hands, toes, feet,
those sort of areas, okay?
All right,
and know the neurologic innervation of the hand.
I think Dr. Geary went over this with you,
hopefully, if not,
I put the, you know,
what's the radial nerve,
median nerve and ulnar nerve?
How to do the test for those
in the supplemental slides.
They love asking that question, okay?
Rhabdo, actually, this is alluded to
by Dr. Levine in the last lecture.
Rhabdo happens with people
who have significant trauma,
a lot of muscle necrosis.
What they will have
is their urine dipstick will be positive,
positive,
the dipstick is positive for, quote, blood
but when you look under the microscope
there's no blood there
because it's all myoglobin
from the muscle injury, okay?
So, a diagnosis of rhabdo
is when their CPK is markedly elevated
and you're now spilling myoglobin
in the urine.
You treat that with fluids, fluids,
fluids, fluids, fluids,
you keep flushing the kidneys.
Okay, Compartment Syndrome.
Compartment Syndrome is the other thing,
injury that can happen to the extremity.
Here you have this crush injury
to an extremity,
the classic is the lower extremity,
but it can be any other extremity,
and when the pressure inside that compartment,
the magic number is greater
than 30 millimeters of mercury,
that's the magic number,
that's when you should call up a surgeon,
a trauma surgeon,
a vascular surgeon, orthopedic,
whoever's available,
they need to then do their fasciotomy
and open up that compartment.
Environmental injuries,
I'll mention it real quick,
there's heat and cold.
Cold and heat ones,
the cold is real easy,
either a frostnip or frostbite,
the difference between the two
is that frostbite,
there's cellular death,
frostnip, there's no tissue loss.
The treatment for frostbite
is you do rapid rewarming
in circulating water,
there, you got it.
Heat, just the opposite,
is the difference between
heat exhaustion and heat stroke.
Very common, you know,
if I'm sure down here in Texas
you'll see a lot of heat related stuff
coming to your ER
and you'd have to decide
if it's exhaustion,
they'll be sweaty,
they'll feel terrible,
but they're sweating
and their neuro exam is normal.
Heat stroke,
you have the temperature greater than 104
and they're having CNS dysfunction.
CNS dysfunction is not,
"I feel terrible and weak",
that's not CNS dysfunction.
They will have,
they will look septic,
they will have some CNS dysfunction,
they can't speak,
they can't do something, okay?
All right, I wanna move on
to the surgical abdomen now,
that's the last 18 minutes of my talk.
That's the other,
we're gonna go,
we're gonna move into a different area.
I've done the environmental stuff now
we're now gonna put our surgeon hats on.
All right, so David mentioned
he's gonna cover upper and lower GI later,
those are the non-surgical stuff,
I'm gonna do the surgical stuff
and when it comes to the surgical abdomen,
there's really only two reasons
to call up a surgeon.
One is the patient has acute peritonitis, right?
They have peritonitis
and a surgeon needs to get involved for that
or they're obstructed.
That's it,
those are the two reasons
to call up a surgeon immediately
that you're gonna want them for.
All right, so let's dig into this
a little bit further, of course.
When it comes to peritonitis,
you have spontaneous bacterial peritonitis,
you have secondary
and you got tertiary.
So, the spontaneous peritonitis
doesn't necessarily need a surgeon,
but it does need some antibiotics, all right,
and this happens in your cirrhotic patients,
typically a gram-negative,
E. coli gets in there
and you need to put them on
broad spectrum antibiotics
that covers particularly E. coli.
Secondary peritonitis is what
you and I almost all,
the more common thing.
This is the appendicitis,
this is the diverticulitis, all right,
and so here you really need
to call up your surgeon
and to have source control.
Get that appendix out,
manage the diverticulitis,
you got the idea,
and then there's tertiary,
which you'll sometimes get
and that is the surgeon took care of,
let's say the appendix,
and oh, they got a post-surgical abcess,
all right, or a post-op infection.
So, those are now more opportunistic infections
and you have to control those.
I will just make in one,
just to distinguish this,
the spontaneous bacterial peritonitis
versus infection
associated with peritoneal dialysis,
just know the diagnosis,
the numbers are just a little different.
You have 250,
greater than 250 white blood cells
for spontaneous bacterial peritonitis.
Peritoneal dialysis is usually due to gram-positives,
usually staph or strep,
and as soon as you have any suspicion of that
and you have any white cells,
you need to cover for staph and strep.
All right, abdominal pain,
when it comes to the elderly,
be careful,
they often have,
they're often harboring something worse.
They more often get hospitalized,
more likely to be diagnosed,
more likely needed surgery,
so, you know, when I have patients
come in with abdominal pain
and they're elderly
and I'm contemplating,
"Ah, it's constipation",
I just take a step back and say,
"Is it really constipation?
Is it something else?"
I just make certain
before I discharge that patient
with constipation as a cause
of that elderly person's abdominal pain.
All right, let's talk about some specific conditions
they can ask you about
when it comes to the abdomen
and that is abdominal wall and hernias.
So, let's talk about hernias,
I like to work my way in.
So, here's a question,
you have a 72-year-old female
presents with a six hour history
of painful lump in her groin.
There's some nausea, no vomiting,
no fever, chills,
just a painful lump in the groin.
You go examine the patient,
the abdomen's fine,
the right groin has a palpable mass below
or inferior to the inguinal ligament.
Despite gentle firm pressure,
the mass does not disappear.
Hmm?
The most likely diagnosis is,
"A, a strangulated indirect inguinal hernia,
B, a reducible direct inguinal hernia,
C, an incarcerated femoral hernia
or D, an incarcerated Spigelian hernia."
All right, so good,
2/3's of you got it,
it's an incarcerated femoral hernia.
Why is it most likely to be
an incarcerated femoral hernia?
Well just recognize the, you know, the difference
between incarcerated and strangulated.
Incarcerated means it's stuck,
you can't reduce it
and when the vascular supply is finally compromised,
now it's strangulated,
that portion of the bowel is dying.
The most common hernias you'll find
are the indirect inguinal hernias,
that's the most common one,
direct is second most common.
When you've got that inguinal hernia,
I love it when the residents
come up and say this to me,
"Oh, well I saw a patient,
they have an indirect inguinal hernia."
I say, "How do you know that?"
"Well, they got a lump there
in the groin right here."
It's like on exam,
you cannot tell if it's indirect or direct,
you can't tell,
you just have the lump there in the groin, okay?
Now the femoral hernias,
right off the bat,
are more common in women
and as I had in that
and said in that question,
it's located below
or inferior to the inguinal ligament,
typically medial to the femoral pulse.
This question comes up sometimes,
"Is watchful waiting appropriate?"
So, you have someone
who's got an inguinal hernia, all right,
they may say, "Doc, do I need
to get this operated on?",
or you might be thinking,
"Should I send 'em to a surgeon?"
Well, this is where you have
shared decision making with the patient.
So, if they've got an inguinal hernia
and it's not bothering them much,
you just happen to pick it up,
"Yep, it's there."
"I didn't even know it,
you know, just not bothering me."
It's completely reducible
and you know,
"I really don't wanna get an operation",
that's appropriate.
Okay, you can do watchful waiting.
You may wanna counsel 'em on the fact
that the chance of it becoming a surgical emergency
is actually very low.
It actually is very, very low.
However, most patients,
about 3/4's,
2/3's to 3/4's of 'em eventually,
eventually find their way
into the hands of a surgeon
'cause it does end up getting uncomfortable
and they'll ask you this question,
"Well, if I got this thing in my groin,
can I still exercise?
Can I still run?
Can I do stuff?"
The answer is yes.
Remember, exercise is good, okay,
it's always the answer on the Boards, okay.
All right, next question,
this is a true case.
"67-year-old patient with a history
of chronic low back pain
presents with six hours
of sudden, severe, diffuse abdominal pain."
His medications include celecoxib
because of his chronic use for his back pain,
three days ago he went to an orthopedic urgent care
because his back pain worsened
and they put him on a Medrol Dosepak.
His vital signs there, you see,
blood pressure's okay,
he's tacky,
his respiratory rate's up,
oh by the way,
that's SIRS, okay? (chuckling)
He's afebrile,
"his abdomen's diffusely tender,
with guarding and rebound,
an upright chest x-ray demonstrates
free air under the diaphragm."
Hmm?
All right,
the most likely diagnosis in this situation
would be an "acute ischemic bowel,
B, a perforated duodenal ulcer,
C, a perforated appendicitis
or D, a perforated diverticulitis."
Good, perforated duodenal ulcer.
That sounds good to me,
that's exactly what it is.
This person's at high risk for just that, okay,
the perforated duodenal ulcer
is the most common cause
for air under the diaphragm
or free air in the abdomen.
All right, why?
Why was this person at high risk?
They're on chronic NSAID use
and then you put 'em on a steroid
on top of it?
Don't do that. (chuckling)
Don't do that.
Nothing good on the gut
when you do that, all right,
and yes, you can,
if you're in your office setting,
you don't have a CT available,
just do the upright chest x-ray,
it's really, really sensitive.
It's old school I know,
but it does get you an answer
and it can detect very, very little air
under the diaphragm.
Okay, all right, next patient.
Something else in the abdomen.
"A 60-year-old patient presents to the ED",
or your office "with three days
of worsening right upper quadrant pain.
The pain radiates to the right scapula,
there's nausea and vomiting."
The temperature, hmm,
that's not good,
it's elevated.
Pulse, hmm, elevated,
blood pressure, not too good,
90 over 45.
He and worse than this,
he's jaundiced,
and his bilirubin's 7.8.
His right upper upper quadrant's tender,
most likely diagnosis here is
"A, acute cholecystitis,
B, ascending cholangitis,
C, gallstone pancreatitis
or D, gallstone ileus."
Now hopefully a lot of you picked B.
2/3's of you did, good,
it's ascending cholangitis.
This gentleman is demonstrating Charcot's triad.
Well, let's get into gallstone disease.
So, who's at risk of getting gallstones?
People, well, there's a family history,
that's one,
obesity, sedentary lifestyle,
cyclic weight change.
They have asked this question in the past
and it's true,
patients who have dramatic loss in weight
such as when they go through bariatric surgery
will precipitate out stones.
(chuckling) I've got a funny feeling
I'll start seeing some reports
not too distant future
that when people are taking
the Wegovy's of the world,
that they start, yeah,
'cause everybody's on them now (chuckling) it seems
that they're gonna start precipitating out gallstones,
so be aware,
be careful with cyclic weight change.
It's not always just cholesterol stones,
by the way,
think about patients
who have high red blood cell turnover
such as your sickler's,
they will have black,
the hemoglobin stones
are the black pigmented stones.
All right, but again,
the cholesterol stones
are the most common ones, 80%.
What do you do if the patient is,
oh they went,
they were 65,
they went for their Triple A exam,
like we talked about earlier,
and, oh, the ultrasonographer just decided
to take a look at the right upper quadrant
'cause, well, they just had some time
and they see some stones.
You know, you get the report back,
gallstones,
you ask the patient,
"You got any belly pain,
right upper quadrant pain?"
"No, I don't have any pain."
So, asymptomatic stones,
what do you do with them?
Nothing, (laughing) okay?
Nothing, all right,
you do not do anything
'cause the vast majority of 'em
will have no problem with them.
Once they become symptomatic,
now you're gonna wanna consider surgery.
All right, so how do they present symptomatically?
All right, I like to do things
anatomically in my brain,
so you can have a stone
sitting there in the gallbladder,
you eat the fatty meal,
it kicks around,
you get right upper quadrant pain
and that's biliary colic, right?
When a stone decides to sit there
in the cystic duct,
now it's obstructive
and so what will happen is that
the bile will start backing up behind it,
it will get infected,
typically with a gram-negative,
you'll then get some right upper quadrant pain
and discomfort.
You'll have a positive Murphy's sign, right,
and positive Murphy's sign,
by the way,
I always ask the residents this,
they always get it wrong,
is you have the patient laying down,
you put your hand in the right upper quadrant,
deep in there
and it's not ouch at that point,
that's a Murphy's sign,
it's you take a deep inspiration,
ah-ah-ah, ah, (inhaling)
and it's cessation with inspiration
is a positive Murphy's sign.
Okay, cessation of inspiration.
All right, now let's say the stone
decides to get into the common duct,
now that was our case scenario,
you're gonna end up potentially
with ascending cholangitis
'cause now you've got that common duct obstructed,
it will dilate,
bile will back up into the liver,
you get jaundiced,
you have right upper quadrant pain,
you'll typically get fever,
again from gram-negatives infecting the area,
that's Charcot's triad,
that was our patient,
ascending cholangitis.
Sometimes the stone decides to go down
and obstruct the ampulla of Vater,
that's gallstone pancreatitis,
and last but not least,
sometimes that you get a huge, huge stone
that will erode through
the wall of the gallbladder
and create a fistula
and it will enter the small bowel
and it will then travel downtown
and then get hung up
at the most narrow portion,
the ileocecal valve,
and then you will get a gallstone ileus,
that's what gallstone ileus is.
All right, everything I just told you
is on this slide.
You can just take this slide out,
it's exactly what I just told you
or you can look at the pretty pictures,
whichever way you best remember it,
(chuckling) all right.
All right, how do you go about evaluating patients?
A patient comes in with some right upper quadrant pain,
you know, you say, "Well,
sounds like gallstone disease."
All right, so you start with an ultrasound.
Suppose you're convinced
it sure sounds like biliary colic,
it sure sounds like gallstone disease,
but there's no stone there.
Well, they may have the functional gallbladder disorder.
It used to be what we call dyskinesia,
but the fancy term is
the functional gallbladder disorder.
So, in those situations,
you send them on for a nuclear scan,
whether you call it a PIPIDA
or a HIDA scan,
whatever your place calls it,
and if they have a a decreased ejection fraction
that's abnormal.
Those patients,
if they go on for their cholecystectomy,
in general, will do well
for their functional gallbladder disorder.
All right, I'm moving from the right upper quadrant
to the right lower quadrant,
appendicitis.
Very common, as you can see,
6% to 7% of the population
at one point in time
will have appendicitis,
it's often due to an appendicolith
that gets lodged in there
and everything behind that appendicolith
gets dilated, infected
and you have appendicitis.
There's some of the number of the signs there,
I will mention,
and why I put in red down below,
the Carnett sign is not a sign of appendicitis.
They've asked this question,
Carnett sign is when you ask the patient
to do an abdominal crunch, okay,
and if the pain persists with the crunch
or it's still tender with a crunch,
when you're crunching,
what are you doing?
You're protecting the peritoneum, right?
So, all you're doing
is getting abdominal wall
origin of that pain, okay,
not inside.
The others are the ones
associated with appendicitis, however,
Rovsing's sign,
Psoas sign, obturator sign,
this is the signs
and how you do them.
All right, so here's a question,
You have a 6-year-old,
you're evaluating for abdominal pain,
"You have a moderate degree of suspicion
that the patient has appendicitis."
He's tender over McBurney's point,
it hurts down there, right,
lower quadrant,
he's not eating,
he may even be vomiting.
"The American College of Radiology
and American Academy of Pediatric recommends
which of the following
as the first choice
to evaluate this patient?"
You should start with an X-ray of the abdomen,
you should start with an abdominal ultrasound,
you should start with a CT
of the abdomen and pelvis
or you should start with an MRI
of the abdomen and pelvis.
What are you gonna send this child for
to help firm up your diagnosis
before you call the surgeon?
All right, good,
hopefully you got this.
Yeah, you start with ultrasound,
everybody's gotten familiar with this now.
You do ultrasound,
yes, ultrasound is really, really useful
in this age group
as well as in patients under the age 14
or if they're pregnant, okay,
that's what you go with,
otherwise in adults you start with CT
and they're non-pregnant, all right?
All right, now there was one question,
in-service question,
and so I put this in
and you may ask me in the Q & A,
so I just, I put this in.
Could it show up with the Boards?
I don't know,
but it's this whole idea
of maybe we don't need to send everybody off
to surgery for their appendicitis.
How about just give them antibiotics
and cool it down
and make it go away?
All right, and there is data out there,
I put a lot of references in there
that suggest that antibiotics alone
will eliminate the need for surgery
in about 2/3's of the cases,
2/3's of the cases,
with less overall complications,
less need for pain meds,
less sick time
and people go back to work earlier
and they found the same in children.
The areas of uncertainty
I've put up there also,
we still are not certain
what the right antibiotic is,
the duration of the antibiotic,
do you keep 'em in house
and observe 'em?
Do you send them home,
bring 'em back?
What if there's an appendicolith?
There's some suggestion
if you have an appendicolith sitting in there,
this may not be as useful
and so you get the idea,
but understand,
they did ask one question about this
and in particular the advantages
of antibiotics over surgery.
All right, intestinal obstruction,
which is the most common cause
of large bowel obstruction?
Is it adhesions from previous surgery,
neoplasm, herniation,
or volvulus?
Yeah, this one,
I know invariably,
I wanna say everyone picks small,
picks adhesions,
I understand that.
If the question was small bowel,
absolutely it's always adhesions,
adhesions, adhesions,
it's usually adhesions in hernias, #2.
If it's large bowel,
the most common cause is neoplasm,
actually, is neoplasm.
All right, there I've already said to you
about small bowel,
large bowel, those are the causes.
We all,
the symptoms of both are very similar,
you get the colicky, abdominal pain,
nausea, vomiting,
diarrhea early on
and eventually no output from below
and then all starts with the vomiting,
vomiting, vomiting
and you've seen that.
On small bowel obstruction
you can do plain films,
you'll see those dilated loops of bowel
and the air fluid levels.
In the case of small bowel obstruction,
how do you management?
You manage that with NG tube,
IV hydration
and non-surgical intervention
works over 50% of the time,
so that's what you try first.
If the patient becomes unstable
or peritonitis develops
or any suggestion of strangulation,
then you go on to surgery.
Large bowel obstruction,
more common in the elderly
because it's most often due to a malignancy
and I'll leave it at that.
You will see here
how a large bowel obstruction occurs,
this is a malignancy down here
in the rectosigmoid area
and everything just backs up behind it
and the cecum is the area
that will dilate preferentially
and may perforate.
Management of that is surgical
and if it's end of life care,
they asked this question once in-service,
you give steroids to help to bring down
whatever edema and swelling is there.
Sigmoid volvulus is another cause
of a large bowel obstruction.
This is a very elderly patient,
typically large floppy sigmoid,
who one day goes shoo,
twists on the mesentary
and that's sigmoid volvulus.
There you have to call up
your GI colleagues
and they need to put a scope in
and detorse this.
There you go,
usually it's 80th decade.
Cecal volvulus is actually a congenital cause,
happens typically in the 5th, 6th decade,
more in women
and one day it will just flop around.
Vascular disease in the abdomen,
I'm gonna mention this real quickly to you,
there's four vascular problems,
typical, common problems
that can happen to the abdomen.
The first is chronic mesenteric ischemia.
What is chronic mesenteric?
That's intestinal angina.
So like, you know,
we talked about claudication
is angina of the legs,
this is intestinal angina.
Who says, you know,
you can't put your atherosclerotic plaque
right there at the beginning of the SMA?
Who tends to get this?
Women more than men, okay,
and they will come in
with postprandial abdominal pain.
They're, it's intestinal angina, okay?
All right, what about acute mesenteric ischemia?
I've already suggested this is
when you have a person who's got AFib,
the clot goes down,
takes a right hand turn
and pops into the SMA
and they infarct all the bowel.
Ischemic colitis,
this is your elderly patient
whose septic,
has a dehydrated low-flow state
where they will,
there's this watershed area
where the middle colic artery
and the inferior mesenteric artery
sort of meet,
typically around the splenic flexure
that can become ischemic
because they're just low-flow,
you know, they're dehydrated,
not getting enough flow to that area
and then there's acute mesenteric venous thrombosis
and just understand,
we always think about DVT
and we always think,
"Oh, just the legs, right?"
Well, no, you have a venous side here
and patients who are predisposed to DVT's
can get their DVT in their mesenteric side.
Pediatric surgery,
all on your supplemental slides.
There's four pediatric surgical conditions
you should be aware of
they can ask you about.
Intussusception,
Meckel's diverticulum,
hypertrophic pyloric stenosis
and necrotizing enterocolitis,
they're all in your handout,
just review those
and we'll go from there.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Dr. Dachs.
(audience applauding)
(inspiring music)